what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios has
made some pretty big changes they have
decided to re-title Agatha coven of
chaos that is no longer that name and
they have changed the release dates for
some of their upcoming Disney Plus shows
of course we'll update you with all of
the changes but the biggest thing that
is coming from this new information that
we're getting today is that we have just
learned that Marvel Studios is
approaching Disney Plus in a brand new
way that fans I think are really going
to love we know that Marvel Studios has
been switching up their strategy a
little bit now but now we are finally
seeing what they are actually doing yes
they have said that they're going to cut
back on Disney Plus shows they're gonna
make fewer Disney Plus shows and space
them further out and now we know exactly
why and we know what their plan is and
we'll go over it in this video but first
big congratulations to d-man 1990 220
for being the winner of the August
giveaway we've contacted you and don't
worry if you didn't win we're starting
our September member giveaway now so if
you want a chance to win an Xbox series
X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items all you got to do to enter
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment on our videos we pick a random
comment on a random video for a winner
each month the winner gets to pick one
item alright like I mentioned we have
some release date shuffles Marvel
Studios has delayed multiple Disney Plus
shows while at the same time we actually
have some release dates for shows that
we didn't really know when to expect
before and this news is coming from The
Hollywood Reporter and they state in
their article thr The Hollywood Reporter
poked around the Marvel scheduling
changes and here's what sources say is
the new rundown it starts with good news
they State as previously announced Loki
season 2 will be the only show to hit
this fall debuting on Disney Plus on
October 6th so Loki is safe it's still
coming on the same release date October
6th it's not getting delayed it's
already done so the strikes don't affect
this and won't affect this so unless
something really unforeseen happens Loki
is locked down in that October 6th
release date so that's great news they
say expectations remain high for the Tom
Hiddleston Owen Wilson fronted series
that centers on Alternate timelines the
season 2 trailer had the biggest digital
debut of a trailer for any Disney plus
series and season one Remains the most
watched Marvel series on Disney plus
then we have an update for what if
season 2 and we never really knew when
this was going to be coming out we've
yet to get a release date for it and we
kind of still don't have an official one
but The Hollywood Reporter says the
second season of emmy-winning animated
series what if Will debut around
Christmas day so not an official release
date but a window and it's important to
note in The Hollywood Reporter notes
this as well that what if season 2 is
not going to be a holiday special it is
simply releasing around Christmas time
apparently what if season 2 was supposed
to be released earlier this year but it
got pushed back several times and
eventually didn't have a release date at
all but now we can lock it down to some
somewhere around December 25th now
moving on to Echo it has been delayed
and this is a little bit concerning
because Marvel Studios has already
decided to release every single episode
of echo at one time all episodes of the
echo series were supposed to hit Disney
Plus on November 29th but now it has
moved to January of 2024 we don't have
an exact date but it will come out
sometime in January and according to the
Hollywood Reporter this is indeed going
to be a direct spin-off of the Hawkeye
series which of course makes sense
Kingpin is going to be the villain of it
and we explored the story of Maya and
Kingpin in Hawkeye and don't forget
Daredevil is going to appear in the Echo
series as well we've heard a mixture of
things about the echo Series so far some
of the Insiders have stated that they've
heard nothing but good things but we've
also heard some rumors that it's not
that good which is why Marvel Studios
has decided to release it all at once
but we also know that Marvel Studios is
kind of experimenting with Disney and
plus right now so this could simply be a
test see how a Disney Plus show will
perform if every single episode is
released at once and Marvel is making
big changes to Disney plus don't worry
we're gonna get into that in just a bit
but first a big one that fans have been
waiting for X-Men 97 the animated series
that is coming that is a continuation of
the classic 1990s series that was on Fox
originally originally when it was first
announced it was supposed to come out
sometime around fall of this year but of
course everything got delayed a lot of
stuff got pushed around and ultimately
it was left without a release date but
now it is set to Premiere in early 2024.
sources who have seen X-Men 97 describe
it as retro and a love letter to the
original and keep in mind that season 2
has already been confirmed for X-Men 97
now for Agatha it is no longer called
Agatha coven of chaos this will actually
be the third title change for the series
it was originally revealed to be Agatha
House of Harkness then they changed it
to Agatha coven of chaos but now its
official name is Agatha darkhold diaries
now it never really had an official
release date but we thought we were
going to be getting it sometime at the
end of this year however it has
unfortunately been pushed back a little
bit to early fall of next year 2024. now
speaking about the title change
variety.com stated that a source with
knowledge of the show told them that the
changing titles are less of a sign of
indecision on Marvel's part and more of
a suggestion that Agatha is up to her
old skulduggery that is literally the
word that they used The Hollywood
Reporter also reports that ironheart has
been delayed indefinitely right now due
to the strikes but The Insider can we
get some toast stated that sources say
that the reason that it's been taken off
the Marvel Studio schedule is to bring
it closer to the armor Wars release and
they've been told that Marvel wants to
go full steam ahead with armor Wars
production post strikes also The Insider
can we get some toast had something to
say about what if season 2 telling us
that there is going to be an episode of
what if season 2 that is what if happy
Hogan Saved Christmas so although what
if season 2 is not a holiday show or a
holiday special for Marvel it will have
a Christmas episode starring happy Hogan
who I assume will be voiced by the one
and only John Favreau now as far as
Marvel Studios changing up their plans
for Disney plus it sounds like via The
Hollywood Reporter they actually have a
pretty decent plan they state that the
writer strike began May 2nd while the
actors went on strike July 14th
significantly impacting production and
development speaking about all of the
release date changes however they went
on to say this at the same time sources
say Marvel wants to focus its efforts to
make each title an event for fans and
audiences the studio has decided that
spreading out its content is a more
prudent strategy and I think I have to
agree on this making these Disney Plus
shows big events rather than just
releasing a ton of different series one
after another very frequently is going
to feel a lot better and a lot more
special when we finally do get Disney
Plus shows they can make them bigger and
they can make them feel more special
there is such thing as having too much
of a good thing it becomes less special
to you and I think that's what a lot of
fans have felt with the frequency of the
Disney Plus shows even if you have liked
all of them they do kind of feel a
little bit less special because you're
getting so many so it's not a bad trade
Marvel Studios is going to release less
Disney Plus shows but hopefully they are
going to be a lot better and feel bigger
and more special which hopefully means
they'll hold a bigger place in our
hearts and Marvel will have a lot fewer
misses and don't get me wrong I'm
somebody who has enjoyed most of the
shows I love Marvel obviously but I do
miss the time during the first three
phases where everything that came out
felt like a really special moment going
to the theater watching an Avengers film
or Captain America film and to be fair
lot of fans felt this with one Division
and Loki it was the start of Disney plus
and the shows were great but
unfortunately we had so much frequency
come out after that and the quality
lacked and it just hit fans the wrong
way and that special feeling was lost
but it sounds like Marvel Studios knows
that and they are fixing it or at least
are going to give it their best shot by
making the Disney Plus shows that they
do release feel like big events and I
think that that is a great plan but let
us know what you think about this in the
comments down below and let us know what
you think about all of these changes
including the title change for Agatha
coven of chaos drop all your thoughts
down below don't forget to like this
video And subscribe to stay up to date
on the MCU and so you can enter our
giveaway and of course you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
anything